mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
la radiodiffusion française vous
présente maintenant dans l'émission
direct le concert de l'orchestré
national qui va être exécutée sous la
direction de manuel rosenthal
au programme la symphonie en ré majeur
de cherubino et en seconde partie après
l'entracte la
tragédie de pérégrine as de pierre
capdevielle
drame de concert en deux parties pour
récitant soli choeur et orchestre
textes de charles exbrayat
ce sera aujourd'hui la première édition
de la version définitive de lèvres avec
le concours de jean hervé de claudine
collard claudine verneuil christiane
quéro et y va de melchior et d'éclairs
de la radiodiffusion française chef des
choeurs even gouverner
la mise en ondes musicales de ce
programme va être assurée par ivan levaï
s voici donc pour commencer la symphonie
l'unique que symphonie de luigi
cherubini qu'elle symphonie en ré majeur
comprend quatre mouvements
lento et allègre d'abord
larghetto cantabile
skertzo haleiwa ça y est le finale
allegro vivace
donc
comment
orchestre national vient d'exécuter sous
la conduite de manuel rosenthal la
symphonie de boccherini symphonie en ré
majeur la seule que le compositeur est
écrite mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
la première partie du programme est
terminée dans un quart d'heure environ
vous pourrez écouter la tragédie de
pérégrine as de pierre capdevielle
textes de charles exbrayat
g de concert en deux parties pour
récitant soli choeur et orchestre
ce sera aujourd'hui rappelons le la
première audition de l'oeuvre dans sa
version définitive
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
la seconde partie du concert de
l'orchestré national dirigé par manuel
rosenthal
être consacrés à la tragédie de
pérégrine hausse
de pierre capdevielle
textes de charles exbrayat
drame de concert en deux parties
pour récitant soli choeur et orchestre
l'oeuvre vous est donné aujourd'hui
en première audition
dans sa version définitive
sous la direction de manuel rosenthal
avec le concours de jean hervé
dans le récitant
de claudine collard
claudine verneuil christiane guiraud et
ivan melchior solistes et des choeurs de
la radiodiffusion française chef des
choeurs even gouverner
première partie
l'an
nous
oh
et
l'inexorable soleil de cet été de l'an
161 fait étinceler les temples de
l'altesse
olympie la ville chère à zeus
oublie d'écouter le bruissement de ses
pinces a créé sous la brise descendu du
mont chronos pour mieux entendre les
clameurs d'une foule chantant la gloire
des athlètes 20
dans l'impitoyable lumière le stade de
marbre blanc semble lac en ébullition la
piste de sable doré scintille sous les
yeux des grecs ça soit fait
en attendant de cris ou sommet les 1000
dialecte de l'hellade les pèlerins tu
discutes les choses de ce qui pour
l'honneur de leur ville vont reprendre
pas route olic a terrible course de fond
faux serrant les dents retenant son
souffle comme on retient un cheval
emballé ménager ses forces rennais sa
vitesse car la piste est long et l'on
doit la parcourir cette fois dans toute
sa longueur
la chaleur est terrible mais personne ne
veut penser qu'au pied de la colline
sacrée
l'alf écoule parmi les herbages où règne
une fraîcheur délicieuse et sur les
grandes heures a trop dans l'ère de la
course chacun supputent les chances des
champions car de tous les coins de
l'hellade ils sont venus athéniens aux
gestes tendres t bar et 10 dans gaye
corinthiens volubile carré 3e vu deux
femmes spartiates vêtue et offredo b1
aux yeux clairs là pour parler de la
coni est traversé par les syllabes
chantante de la tique sur la piste les
entraîneurs mast une dernière fois les
muscles de leurs élèves dont la
nervosité croît à mesure car on se lève
et que ce fait plus appel remous des
clameurs
la lutte a
rappelé dans son manteau rouge monte sur
le socle dont l'ombre net caressera
l'épaule du vainqueur dans sa foulée
suprême une fois regard l'écho des
trompettes monte à travers la foule
carispe et dans son attente muet
ouais
lalita recari le nom de ceux qui vont
s'élancer sur le sable chaud
lopy strates est avance
ofra strauss de del
caribe moss 2007
pyj d'ordre de trèbes
et remet pause dos par
l'hypnose d'attraits
mon
ovo ville
et pour les jo
ils sont partis arif reste aux lampistes
rod est la plus belle foule général
voyez vous voyez bien défauts sont
proches mais non quand ils se taisent
car une antenne 2 premiers stades mais
voilà l'été automne prochain finale a
été
l'affairé de
tenay premier la grande finale et on est
bon
regardez
issa t
chanceux
oui
à
e
lomé
lalita
rauzan sur le front depuis isidore la
couronne symbolique chante la gloire du
vainqueur
sus aux yeux chargés des clercs te
prenne sous sa protection aux piscines
hors et que la gloire de toutes régions
soient portées par le vent jusqu'à ted
ta patrie mur d'amay
et
hu
que les prêts
joda force inépuisable
ou aux jeunes olympio nick que les
thébains fier d'avoir nourri dionysos
héraclès grave tonneaux sur les murs de
leur semble heureuse
est amer
oh
ouais
à
mon nom va cuire de bouche en bouche
déco en écho de file en ville
la résonnera au large des colis
nourrira dans les âmes ou par les légers
chantera dans les eaux courantes à
travers nos plaines
jusqu'à ce qu'un matin m la glorieuse se
réveille toujours au nom de gloire
heureuse
amer
m
à
ah ah
les fils de terre on pisse d'or ont
tissé de l'endroit la planche laine
quand elles recueilleront des épaules
accablé par la renommée les jeunes
hommes répare les champs qui diront on
triomphe est dans les temps à venir
domfessel
manie l'art ou trop longtemps sera dans
la mémoire des hommes et sur les lèvres
des enfants et reste amer aux pieds d'or
c'est alors le sel
sel au milieu de l'endive endroit
l'enivrant de joie populaire
pérégrine hausse
apparaît
pérégrine hausse le cynique des greens à
ce qu'il sait que blasphémer peregrino
ce qui suit sa route dans un remous
d'extravagance et de scandar
peregrino ce que seuls les mauvais
admire pour sa gouaille pour cette
délirante contradiction pour son
impudence et son mépris des dieux
pérégrine hausse se refuse de
reconnaître et de glorifier pizy d'or
l'olympe ionique à ceux qui s'en étonne
tout trajet le vieux est rusé manière de
mots
rétorque que ni la rapidité
ni la force d'un athlète le plains pas
lancé l'orgueilleuse droit de celui qui
méprise la peur la souffrance ou la
douleur ou de celui qui volontairement
met fin à sa vie pour empêcher les dieux
de trancher à leur guise le fil de son
existence
mais ceux qui l'écoutent se moque de lui
et le défi d'agir selon ses paroles
pérégrine ans grise et du désir
d'étonner ces grecs ces petits allons
d'un feu des jeux prochain il mettra fin
à ses jours en se jetant dans les
flammes d'un bûcher
élevé de ses propres mains on va les
plus sages de ceux qui l'écoutent lui
montre-t-il l'aphonie de sault terrible
serment pierrick linos s'obstine et
déclare je mourrai
sur ce bûcher
dont la clarté illuminera vos faces
obtuse
d'insister et ben ali
je jure par les dieux
deuxième partie
l'an
et les lads s'étant replonger lancé
peine et dans ses espoirs les années
passent et
le tumulte des jeux qui virent le
triomphe de fizi d'or le thé ben alla
jusqu'à devenir et tables comme l'eau
d'un fleuve déborder parvenu au bout de
sa course
l'année
164 à son tour se fondit dans la course
du temps
alors
montade les lidd la rumeur sacré
annonciatrice des jeux de l'an nouveau
nom
comme les cercles riz dans la surface
d'un lac sous la chute d'un caillou les
échos d'olympie s'étalèrent plus un peu
sur le mode hellénique
amenant avec eux la paix
et la joie et lisses la ville sacré
héros partir d'annoncés héros grec
l'ouverture des jeux
oh
et
moi
une
voici maintenant au dernier soir des
olympiades
c'est le soir
où peregrino doit tenir son serment
affolée de peur il se terre depuis des
jours dans sa cavale comme un renard
dans sa tanière
et puis en lot ou d'un instant à l'autre
peuvent retentir des voix vengeresse
on ne jure pas impunément par les dieux
le sol nikos sont les missiles nikos le
sahara sont uniques à sin-le-noble part
à sa recherche
pour l'aider dans l'acte suprême qu'il a
volontairement décidé
dans la molle douceur de la nuit
violette il cherche la maison de
pérégrine hausse d'un bois de pin
s'élèvent les voix des prêtresses
d'athéna qui le guident et plus loin le
champ d'un roseau trouant la nuit du
indique la demeure de son ami
monde
on
oh
ans
et
ninon santé
badiane de la vie le
monde
ah ah
l'effort
ouais
m
oh
halte au fond de sa demeure comme une
bête traquée
s'efforçant à ne pas écouter les bruits
de la nuit on gens sont en bois son
amertume et son mépris
peregrina ce ne veut pas entendre la
voix de son ami
sonica stand pourtant de lui montrer les
paroles qu'il a prononcées
l'enchère
peregrino s'il faut acquitter les rires
et north il te faut payer qui a lâché
imprudemment des mots que d'autres ont
ramassé
tu as trop aimer les mots peregrino ce
tronc chéri les rires c'est pour braver
tes concitoyens que tu t'es vanter
d'avoir commis le péché d'adultère ont
promis de jeunes garçons tuer ton père
renier sa foi chrétienne
cette nuit la femme déshonoré le garçon
salies ton père mort le divin crucifié
marge marche sur les chemins qui mènent
ta maison
pérégrine hausse
n'attend pas que leur ombre envahi stade
mère peregrino s'il faut aller là où tu
as promis de torrents
l'instant est venue du a juré par les
dieux c'est une croix plus odieux les
autres n'y croira
les épreuves des jeux sont terminés les
gosses les athlètes vainqueurs regagnent
leur colère
à
non
hahaha
et oh
et
hé
ouais
or
eh ouais
aïe
m
ah ah
la peau
m
et
là
hé hé
sonicos poursuit 1,6
peregrino ce fonds piché il faut que tu
ailles il faut que tu tires hors jeu qui
conduirait moi même toujours tu as vécu
de mode parole perry green hausse
peut-être les dieux sont ils juste en
obligeant aujourd'hui à jouer ton sang
sur des paroles
pérégrine hausse tu as toujours su
persuader et bien maintenant il s'agit
de ta vie cette épreuve devant tous
cette humiliation devant ce peuple te
vaudront peut être leur clémence qui
sait leur pardon est à vis sera so à toi
de gagner une fois encore allons ami
vient
respire la nuit
comme les douze hommes et les cas
ah ah
et deux amis dans la nuit tranquille
karen le lieu où la foule cruel à élever
le bûcher ne doit mourir peregrino
peregrino ce
que la peur de la mort part d'une
certaine majesté
puise dans sa peur même la force de
parler à la multitude alto savoir alors
montrent trop long ardente tendu un
sinueuse et un peu convaincant ces
paradoxes et sophisme fusent fulgurant
éclatant sa voix monte monte monte
toujours
conquérante encore une fois magique et
victorieuse enfin devant ses fils
retourne et fasciné par son incroyable
il oppose il s'écrit
gré
afin que ce ne soit pas frustré de ce
fut que vous vouliez faire brûler en son
honneur
donnez une temps
là et maintenant
la fumée attentes montent vers leur
deuxième phase
j'espère des princes haussmann ou
favorable
c'est ce maître des cieux épargne nous
ta colère
non mais m
ce
contrôle
oh non
oh
m
3 0
c'est là
m
ses parents
et
c'est rire ce qu'un brutale
maintenant ce riz
jaillit de la foule ce rire qui se
propageaient gaye la multitude des armes
désarçonne territoire
une terreur soit par de lui tandis que
les bots
s'accroche qu'au niveau
sur ses lèvres
rien
mais la cote
trop
là
à
pour abc
ah ouais
je
c'est ainsi que mourut peregrino ce
parce qu'elle était arrivé au bout
des mots
la tragédie de ferrer greenhaus
de pierre capdevielle
textes de charles exbrayat
drame de concert en deux parties pour
récitant soli choeur et orchestre
vous a été donné avec le concours de
jean hervé
dans le récitant
de claudine collard claudine verneuil
christiane guiraud et ivan mais le
quillard solistes et des choeurs de la
radiodiffusion française
chef des choeurs even gouverner
c'était ce soir sous la direction de
manuel ros un talent
la première audition de lèvres dans sa
version définitive
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
le programme du concert de l'orchestré
national et terminer la mise en ondes
musicales on était assuré par yvan attal
reyes